tiny po Shar the show hey how you doing
buddy I'm good man how are you I'm
excellent it's santon at the moment
mental what is that uh it's this is
actually the first year I've ever been
here for every other year I've somehow
managed to avoid it but basically the
worst people you know dress up like
Santa Claus and they get hammered like
it's what time is it right now it's like
3 o' yeah yeah so they get hammered in
the afternoon like did you see the lines
yeah for the bars like bars right now
are at it's like uh say Patty's Day kind
of lines right now so it's what this
like Saturdays before Christmas or
something I guess yeah and uh but it's
yeah yeah I guess and uh it's like like
there's lines literally bending around
the corner for just pubs and everyone's
dressed up every dressed up everybody's
getting like really drunk in the
afternoon comedy on Santa Santa Con day
is like generally really bad it's really
bad cuz everybody shows up wasted and uh
fights like what's the demographic of
people that attend Santa come that's a
good question you know what it's pretty
diverse like I was looking around yeah
it's like you're looking you're like
it's a bit of everybody it's pretty wild
but uh yeah so cuz it took me like just
uh a lot longer to get over here from my
house and I was wondering I'm like what
is going on and then I start kind of you
know I was listening to like my my audio
book and I'm looking around I see all
the Santa Claus hats I go and then when
I got out of right yeah yeah but then
when I got out I okay it's happening
yeah have you got your IG back yet no
what's happened was the what's the story
essentially what happened is there's
like I know some people who are kind of
high up fairly in the world of
technology a lot of people have a lot of
opinions but essentially on October we
actually figured out last night it might
be as a result of you actually fantastic
yeah yeah yeah we we think that that's
like my new uh current theory so on on
October 8th I've had an Instagram
account for 12 years never had a post
taken down y nothing no issues at all
and then on October 8th I got uh logged
into Instagram and it says your
account's permanently suspended for uh
sexual solicitation which is essentially
what they get for like only fans girls
right I'm like what the hell this must
be a m I'm like you know oh this must be
a mistake right so I appeal it and in
Instagram there's just like a blue
button that just says would you like to
appeal and I press the button and then
one minute later they say we've denied
your appeal and then uh there's but they
say if this is a mistake uh you can
write a little like kind of blurb to
them so I write a thing I get it back
and I'd been posting some content
remember like basically the thing that
you showed Douglas Murray right about
the gay for Gaza Gaye for Gaza stuff
right and I was making fun of those
people and uh and you'd have to think
that a lot of people who probably work
in content moderation at meta probably
side more with those people than me than
the person making fun of those people
right so anyways I get it back two days
later exact same thing happens I get
suspended again same thing and I'm going
pretty hard on like you know posting
about the Israel Palestine conflict
again same thing happens and then um get
it back again though and then on no
November 8th which would be one month
ago exact same thing happens this time
though I appeal press that blue appeal
button lose one minute later and there's
no option for me
to three strikes and you're out I guess
right and so and then we were talking
last night uh and because we he brought
up the thing and then I went and you
posted that thing on November 6th that
went super viral now I don't know if
it's related cuz I was obviously having
issues before then but I have like a
Target on my back [__] splash splash
Zone dirty I guess but but at meta like
they put a Target on me and so I have
one friend who thinks either it's some
content moderator there who just like
doesn't like me saw that I had a bunch
of stuff like going viral and they were
just like we got to get rid of this guy
someone my one friend thinks that maybe
someone actually literally paid money
because there's this whole black market
like underground economy with um like
Instagram and and because I I think it's
related to the only fans stuff because
only fans girls they promote only fans
on Instagram make tons of money then
they get kicked off but then they're
happy to pay $2,000 what I have to pay
to get to maybe get my thing yeah it's
just like a tax for and they're happy to
pay wasn't there like rumors that these
girls were offering to suck off yeah
there was well that that apparently kind
of put a a wrenching thing that one girl
who went on no jumper and she's like
I've been kicked off like 10 times and I
just keep
yeah like [__] some guy at Instagram
and keep getting it back you considered
that ah that'll be up next yeah that's
my that'll be my my Hail Mary because
I'll tell you what very difficult to be
a working comedian without
Instagram I mean it's that's where
everybody kind of consumes you know you
it's funny because it used to be uh
probably 10 years ago maybe Twitter and
then but now Instagram Tik Tok those are
the kind of places I don't see any
comedians doing [__] on Twitter yeah I I
mean it's just just not that kind of I
post like I posted my whole special my
most recent special it's on Twitter oh
right cool and you know whatever I have
like a decent amount of views on it but
it just that's not the place that drives
people to maybe go see you live or
consume your comedy content it's a
different type of person on Twitter it's
just a different like I was actually on
the train over here and I saw I've been
noticing it more because I take the
train in New York I'll look at like what
people are doing on their phones and
very recently I've noticed more people
are on Twitter than ever before I never
used to see people on Twitter
interesting they'd be on Instagram Tik
Tok Snapchat or whatever and now I do
actually see people on Twitter but
anyway so I'm currently in the process
of paying some guy and then hopefully I
get it back hey if you know how to fix
Instagram accounts getting tou crazy
thing is I've had a number of people say
like I have a hook like my friend works
at at meta or whatever and and then
they're like yeah they they tried
through their internal recovery system
and they're like upholding your band
like you really pissed somebody off dude
I have a friend who was trying to get
his 01 Visa um to come over to America
he already had his visa and was trying
to flip it again again in like whatever
the conservative leaning [__] world
and someone somewhere did a thing like
pressed a button that just delayed his
entire Visa by nine months like you can
like put a a question in yeah yeah you
could just yeah like a request for
[__] say like a request for more
information or n months of just like hey
get [__] you don't get to come back in
the country yep yep yeah yeah yeah it's
weird because I'm so I'm so non-c
conspiratorial with like most of the
[__] that I think about but then even at
a low level like [__] like that yeah
it's like that's just some guy like
that's got a vendetta or is unhappy yeah
it's just someone saw something trending
that was uh you know cuz I had like when
I got kicked off that's the thing you
only get kicked off once you're kind of
popping off right and then and then
there's more no car about the nobody
cares about the person exactly right so
but but so anyways I had a few things
and yeah someone just see something go
like this guy I work at
meta F go [__] yourself yeah and just
and I guess I'm not quite at that you
know if you were massive a million
followers yep probably a little more
diff yeah there's a Zone in the middle
big enough to be noticed not so big that
you can't reach people to like get it
back right and so I mean a lot of people
hear about it that I know and they're
like because here's the craziest thing
about the algorithm which people do not
realize is the algorithm decides what
you see right obviously because it's not
like um chronological
but because it decides what you see
people are so programmed that like so
when I got deleted people don't know my
account's
deleted I'm just they just forget you
exist right they don't know you're gone
like literal family and stuff like my my
girl my fiance's cousin was like why
hasn't Danny posted anything in a month
like she messaged her that she goes why
isn't Danny been posting anything and
she's like oh he got kicked off it's the
same as someone dying it's like the
digital equivalent of being communic
yeah it's like excommunicated but like
people don't even unless they're like
the Die Hard Die Hard fans look they're
like looking and then they look but
otherwise I mean and not even that so
some people were I was getting DMS being
like is this actually you they don't
even believe it Jesus like they're like
they don't even you know and even in my
bio it says like yes deleted this is me
blah blah blah and then but you're not
verified anymore and so it's it's mental
wow yeah that's crazy we'll see I had a
I had Whitney Cummings on the show about
a month ago and I was super impressed
with her like she's great she very very
impressive she said to me before I went
on tour in order for art to imitate life
you have to live a life yeah and it was
her explanation for why comedians just
talk about airports dinner and comedy y
because if you're on the road that's all
you know and this was a month ago and
since then all I've done is be on the
road for one full month all I've done is
be on the road and I've found myself
having conversations with my friends
about all that I've got to talk about is
like airports and check-in and luggage
and shows and what I had for dinner last
night and that's it I mean when that's
your life that's your life right it's so
strange yeah yeah that's I I know like
sometimes you will have a joke something
happens at the airport and you're like
it's the most comedian comedy ever right
and you're like but this is this still
is funny but yeah it is that kind of
thing you're like yeah you have and that
that's why I do try and make a point of
doing stuff you know like traveling and
having a life and like traveling not for
comedy you know cuz a lot of comics were
like yeah I'll go somewhere if I'm doing
a show but did you do Asia recently uh
recently no I've been I've been to
Southeast Asia though I spent I spent uh
like 15 years ago spent a lot of time
there oh okay see but yeah I've been
I've been thinking about that I can kind
of see I know that it's everyone hates
it it's like comedians just talking
about comedy and oh you know the the
crowd and the venue and all the rest of
the stuff but if that's like the [__]
front and center of your life what else
is that I will say the one thing about
Twitter which there's like this
compulsion which I'm sure you've had and
I try to avoid it at all costs is to
public blast some company like that's
wronged you because you're like I don't
even know if there's any real reason to
have Twitter other than the like to be
able to call out call out yeah you know
be like oh and sometimes they're like oh
they really and you're like I could
really just make a stink right now and
feel it's like you got a dopamine Rush
feel righteous yeah as you do it it's
it's I don't know there's definitely an
upper bound on how many times you can
get away with doing that there used to
be an account called DJ's complaining
yeah which was just all of like Testo
like arguing with his bags not being
allowed to be in carry on and stuff like
that and the problem is sometimes it
does work so then you're kind of uh
positively reinforced to you again yeah
yeah keep go keep going it's the it's
the internet equivalent of do you know
who I am yeah exactly it's the Twitter
equivalent of yeah and I mean if you're
a big enough account some some Airlines
like oh we don't need this bad publicity
yeah but really what's going to happen
they're going to the guy that looks
after the social media is going to find
the flight that you're on and like tweet
the a Hostess to say hey make sure that
he's allowed to have his nuts or you
should give a second exactly yeah the
outcome is nothing yes and normally
they're like weather delays you know
where it's actual frustration where like
they can't do some like you know it's
shaking your hand at the [__] Moon
I'm not trying to defend Airlines but
sometimes these you know it is like a
pointless thing obviously sometimes uh
they do lose your luggage and stuff it's
kind of the equivalent of like an
internet Karen in a way to just be like
[__] world Logistics guess the ideal
scenario is you tweet a thing and then
their stock price drops 10% you know and
you're like I just cost them $4 billion
who was it that was it Cristiano Ronaldo
that moved a Coke can I think away from
in front of him was he Cristiano Ronaldo
oh and like replace it with like a
Gatorade or something yeah yeah like
there was a Coke can in front of it I'm
sure it was Cristiano Ronaldo maybe a
couple of years ago and he like just got
the can and moved it out of shot and the
stock price [__] plummeted dude yeah
Cristiano Ronaldo [__] knew it I knew
it um have you been watching the Britney
Spears Arc recent yeah I mean I was I
was day one being like they should not
be removing this conservatorship from
from the jump so this is very much
chickens coming home to roost I mean she
obviously have you ever heard the the
saying with child stars where like the
point that you become super famous is
the point where you stop developing like
as a person Arrested Development ESS so
it's like that's why Michael Jackson was
like a 13-year-old interesting so she's
like a six-year-old she was like super
you know Disney Club whatever Mickey
Mouse Club and like maybe whatever she
got really famous but she's like a child
and then uh and it kind of tracks not
for everyone obviously but it kind of
does track but yeah like you see I don't
know if she's on medication or anything
but you can just see it in the eyes she
either is or should be yeah but you can
see it in the eyes like there's there's
not a lot of activity in the eyes it's
so it's it makes me feel uncomfortable
like I don't follow her but you know you
just stuff surfaces my fiance const my
fiance loves and constantly cuz Lov her
or is like watching it like a slow
motion car crash honestly chicks
like uh they no not like a slow motion
car guys like if you're EMP like most
girls are pretty empathetic and
emotionally tuned in and can see what's
going on how do you not look at Britney
and go this person needs some [__]
help and also needs to stop posting
selfies of her dancing in her hallway
yeah yeah and she looks mental I I mean
the one with the knives that end being
like the meme and stuff Britney Spears
puts aside family drama post a racy
Instagram video of her running her hands
over her body while promoting Victoria's
Secret bras and underwear yeah it's like
I watched this video on it's like her in
bed yeah I saw my girl sent that to me
she she just what the [__] is going on
but when they say promoting like
Victoria Secret's like we don't have
anything yeah we like we don't have
anything to do with this I'm just
wearing it yeah yeah just
wearing like Calvin Klein it's like
Calvin Klein podcast yeah uh I mean she
seems like she's got something uh
mentally going on I don't know like does
she tour anymore does she have like a
residency I don't know I don't think
that she's done a show in in a while
very long time but here's the other
thing all of her videos are filmed on
what looks like a 2011 Blackberry which
doesn't give like sane like that like
the Android yeah yeah totally come on
Deno I I yeah I don't know I don't know
what needs to happen with her so that
people are concerned but you know it's
it sounds like she had this
conservatorship for a reason reason yeah
there was a real reason for it and uh
but you know when the tides turn in
public
perception yeah that's true people want
to kind of get behind the person who has
an overbearing parent and father
specifically it's like man versus woman
in this as well yeah it h takes all of
the boxes yeah so did you see do you
know a meat Canyon do you know that guy
he does those uh illustration videos oh
yeah yeah yeah he's really great so he's
got a second Channel called Papa meat
which is pretty good and he did a
reacting to swifties thing yeah he ended
up getting tons of death threats oh yeah
yeah they're crazy so I mean Britney
Spears I maybe has some fans and that
conservative ship thing was like people
were chasing after that the at least the
advantage you have if you do criticize
Britney Spears is her fans aren't rabid
and totally current like everyone's kind
of just like historical fans yeah Taylor
Swift has very motivated unbelievably
motivated fans so yeah he had fullon
death threats from what he well cuz cuz
uh ber Spears doesn't have 13-year-old
fans y right and those are like the
13-year-old girls maybe the meanest
meanest iteration of a human that can
possibly exist on the other side of it's
like Hamas and then 13-year-old yeah
yeah yeah like if you could like get uh
you know if Taylor Swift became uh like
Muslim or something like like Islamic
Jihad the West would
fall we'd be done yeah I I saw a video
this was before the most recent tour
kicked off and someone had taken one
from inside of a stadium you know you're
in the the gang way you're kind of
walking around the side maybe like kind
of high up and you could hear the music
and see the crowd and she's videoing the
crowd like inside the stadium and
they're all singing along and stuff and
then she pans to outside where there's a
car park and there's 40,000 people in
the car park yeah singing along with the
show that they couldn't get tickets to
get into oh sure I mean my my friend he
has a six-year-old daughter and his
daughter was like I want go in Toronto
to see Taylor Swift and he went and
looked and tickets were like two tickets
were $55,000 to get in just to get in
we're not talking like like I mean this
the r Roger Center well it's all resale
because it's like all scalpers by them
so it's the only way to get them really
other than like this Lottery but
everybody was complaining I mean this is
equalent to being like in subsaharan
Africa and wanting an American visa yeah
pretty much but it made it to like like
Congress was even talking about it
because the scalpers were getting them
all and then the markup was so insane
like it was um we actually had a guy who
on our boyscast patreon uh called in or
like not called sent in a message he
wanted advice and he's like I want to go
I have tickets for Taylor Swift in
Denver and I want to take this girl on a
first date and then we looked up the
resale price he's like should I take
this girl on a first date to Taylor
Swift and we looked up the resale price
and they were like $2,000 a ticket I'm
like you can't take a girl on a first
date that cost five grand like after
whatever four grand and then everything
else I'm like no you just can't do that
I'm like s yeah too much too much over
so these these scalpers are like the
martinelly of Taylor Swift conert they
bought like [__] DEA Pro or whatever
it is and then pumped the price up yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah they just I mean
they're opportunists and they uh but
they have all these crazy like programs
and stuff that are able to Ed shearon
had a thing I'm pretty sure you had to
submit ID for each individual ticket to
kind of get around this yeah there's
some that do that where you have to just
like I can't remember who but you have
to like show ID she's going to make a
billion dollars from this tour I think
it's like the most already the highest
grossing tour in history yeah that's uh
I mean good for her I guess [__] wild
I don't I don't listen to it but I mean
I'm not the type of person to you know
dude there was a people should go watch
that Papa me video once I finished with
this it's pretty [__] interesting um
she did a movie there was like a Taylor
Swift movie yeah yeah it was just a
concert yeah I think so maybe and it was
like maybe behind the scenes tour Vlog
or some other stuff and they must have
given out uh like LED batons so it's
kind of half like a party yeah in the
cinema whilst it's also the thing on the
TV and there's videos from inside and
the credits are rolling and the girls
have got out of their seats and they
stood underneath the [__] projector
like dancing in a circle like all
holding hands it's like halfway between
a rave a seance a [__] sermon and a
cinema watch
my friend uh Alex Byron he's a comedian
in Canada he did a video where it was at
one of these movie showings or whatever
and for Taylor Swift and then he kind of
like picked his spot where it was just
before it was starting and everybody
they were waiting for it to start and
then he came in and pretended that he
was work he worked for the theater and
he goes sorry everybody um but we're
having an issue with the with the
projector so there's going to be uh
we're not going to be showing the Taylor
Swift but instead we'll be showing uh
the John Mayor documentary or whatever
and every body and then his girlfriend
just to get it started his girlfriend
started throw cuz she was filming she
started throwing stuff at him and then
like people were like Boo and going
insane pretty funny we went to were you
with us when um we went to uh Cheesecake
Factory and it was the night of the
barie movie Jesus Christ so I didn't
know that the Barbie movie was getting
released that night okay and we went
to Gro Center what's it called The Grove
The Grove yeah la yeah dude so we get
out of the car and it's just armies of
women in pink yeah like New York was
like that too [__] platoons of them
yeah did you see it I didn't see it no I
haven't seen it I haven't seen it no I
don't see movies like I used to no uh
bums me out they recently did a Killian
Murphy and margar Robbie did a like
thing together like an interview I think
it was for Vanity Fair or variety or
something like that where they they like
finally got those two like the barbin
Heimer together thing to about each
other uh I got of ectomy due to climate
grief
now we just talked about this on the
voice cast what do you think I I mean
the natural logical conclusion is if you
are so worried about human impact on
climate you kill yourself right if you
really
care right like isn't that like okay
well you know if you want to get a
vasectomy I can do you one further right
right it's crazy I mean these people are
mental they're their their brains have
been so destroyed with uh this like
anxiety and fear about the future like
you
know civiliz humanity is not the type of
thing you want to bet against like there
it kind of always finds a way you know
like everybody's like oh my God we're
doomed like this doomeris I it's
probably
existed forever there's never and you
know and yet here we are so I don't know
what what do you think about it for
about a year and a half I'd been
offering to get ectomy to do more than
just talk about how the world didn't
need any more humans in and around our
old Nova Scotia house i' periodically
make that horizontal Civ scior mime to
reiterate my offer news of rising
temperatures on the kitchen radio finger
snip Atlantic Ocean looking more and
more Disturbed finger snip even back
then in 2007 the North Atlantic
hurricane season was intensified due to
climate change snip
snip Daryl my then partner called out
from a few rows back in a crowded flight
we'd originally been seated together but
relocated so mom could sit with her kids
when I look back over the packed seats
amidst the Roar of burning engines she
smiled at me and minded a scissor cut
with two fingers yes she finally said in
a Gest gesture understandable only to me
my then partner called out this sounds
like a guy who did and now is no longer
with the person who yeah also an
interesting thing here because this is
an ultimate in virtue signaling
obviously to say like I'm saving the
planet by not reproducing and then they
insisted on including no but they
insisted on it's interesting they insist
on including which is unnecessary that
they were not they were sitting
separately because they had to give up
their seats so a mother could sit with
their
child like that's like a weird thing
you're like okay you didn't have to say
that other than you just have to be the
best the best human possible and
everybody else who's reading this is
just scum that's part of why it was so
thrilling when my now wife Gizelle Vol
voluntarily mentioned not wanting kids
on our first date three years later we
got married and moved in a kind of
working honeymoon to sweaty equatorial
Singapore admittedly our next four years
of travel around Asia made us more a
part of the climate crisis problem than
the solution basically I decided to
carbon offset my destructive selfish
Lifestyle by not propagating my own DNA
and instead traveled the world th this
is like a borderline onion article yeah
from not that long ago and it's but this
is the CBC this is this is Canadian
broadcasting this is government funded
uh propaganda right here did you see I
came up with this idea of toxic
compassion do you read my little uh no
haven't seen that all right so uh toxic
compassion is the prioritization of
short-term emotional Comfort over
everything else over truth reality
actual long-term outcomes flourishing
everything it optimizes for looking good
rather than doing good people would
rather claim that body fat has no
bearing on health and mortality outcomes
to avoid making overweight individuals
feel upset even if this causes them to
literally die sooner or have a worse
quality of life people would rather say
that children growing up in single
parent households suffer no worse
outcomes than those from two parent
homes even if this misleads parents
children and teachers about why kids
behave the way they do campaigners would
sooner shout defund the police as a
response to what they perceive as unfair
treatment of criminals even if there's
results in more crimes being committed
against people from those minority
backgrounds due to the abandonment of
police officers from those areas so it's
people that say what they think sounds
good but ultimately might net a negative
outcome and Peterson said it's the
prioritization of short-term emotional
Comfort over long-term thriving it's
going to hurt now but the consequences
long-term are positive you just don't
want to hurt anybody's feelings but you
disregard what the actual long-term
outcome is the same as with this yeah
bloke yeah yeah yeah I mean of course
I'm actually just listening right now to
um uh Jonathan height the codling of the
American mind and and they talk about
like he's he's talking about like all
the safetyism stuff where essentially it
has these actual uh like negative
outcomes you know because some kid got
like abducted in like the 70s and then
they like essentially um were were
clamping down so hard on kids that it
actually made them worse off you know
because you just you don't let them go
outside and because like you know
obviously it's tragic that a kid got
abducted or whatever there was actually
he talks about I can't even believe this
I had to look it up yesterday in 2015 in
Missouri this family in order to teach
their six-year-old a lesson about not
going with strangers abducted him and
like renditioned him and from like a
mall and they put like a bag on his head
and then they like a mock execution like
basically like the craziest lesson you
could ever imagine and then this trauma
is going to teach you not to let it
happen again yeah don't go home with
strangers or whatever and like I don't
even think he did I don't think there
was an in they just abducted him to kind
of teach him this lesson uh you know
kind of get ahead of it preemptively
well that's the [__] horseshoe of
like helicopter parenting that it comes
back around to just super extreme
mistreatment of your kids yeah in the
guys of you know I'm helping them you're
like this kid is going to have this
trauma forever one on the other the one
on the other side that's like oh yeah my
kid will be fine it's like it's the same
idea my kid will be fine my kid will be
fine with me mock [__] abducting him
from this thing but there's no shortage
of those kids who who were like yeah my
parents worked and you know I had a lot
of autonomy and I was fine I seemed to
be okay I was fine maybe I got a little
bit of trouble but you see the stuff
about uh peanut allergies the increase
in peanut that was that was another one
and Jonathan thing was because they it
like tripled the amount of peanut
allergies because they removed peanuts
yeah so if you grow up in a household
that has a washing machine like a
dishwasher that doubles your chances of
asthma and if you grow up in a house
that has a dog it halfs your chances of
asthma because you just get exposed to
dirt so basically you double and then
you double again the chances of it why
the dishwasher dishwasher presumably
just
cleans so in such a sterile way that you
don't get the tiny little doses of germs
and the same for dogs dogs coming in and
out bringing dirt in like playing in the
grass Etc um so yeah there's just ways
where you can sterilize the environment
so much that instead of it making kids
and people safer what it does is creates
such a protected environment that there
is nowhere that they never deal with any
kind of discomfort and this is
culturally
ideologically psychologically mentally
emotionally the exact same thing we see
with toxic compassion yeah I mean I'm
waiting for the shoe to drop on uh hand
sanitizer being bad for you you think
there's so many things we me and Ryan
were just talking about it how all the
stuff that used to be bad for you is now
good for you like remember I don't know
if but like my mom was very much even
still she doesn't come around to you
know she like you got to eat breakfast
you have to eat breakfast it's like you
you'll die you'll have if you don't eat
breakfast now everybody's like don't eat
breakfast or it's like you got to eat
now everybody's like fasting like you
know it's all the stuff it's it's
literally Bro Science has beat down mom
science and uh mom science is just kind
of reeling but uh it just I I don't know
I won't be surprised if it'll be
something similar with the hand
sanitizer where they go people are hand
sanitizing too much and it's causing a
rise and whatever down stream from that
yeah well we we've been doing these meet
and greets after the show uh which is
really great but you do realize that
like if if anybody of these 600 people
that I've just shook hands and taken a
photo and like hugged or like you know
like SLA five with if any of them it's
like I've just got I got it all we did
get Co all of us got Co separately James
in Australia Luke in the UK me in Austin
we all got Co about two months before
the show at the tour began and we were
like tour antibodies like [__] yeah like
we've done it I'm going to be immune
immediately went on tour and just got
wrecked by like other like different
viruses yeah yeah I mean that's that's
kind of the nature of uh of how it goes
but yeah I don't know it's unavoidable
like I was I was just on the train over
here one thing I I still find so
difficult to understand is couples where
one's masked and one's
not because surely the one that's
unmasked will then give you whatever
you're trying to avoid right like am I
missing
something but I see it all the time
you're like a couple where one's
Mas but like how you're gonna get in the
same bed tonight yeah like you're GNA
kiss later
so I I I don't know I don't know maybe
there's someone who's way smarter than
me who can explain that to me because I
I see it all the time like I saw it
literally just on the train right over
here we were in ban in uh Alberta yeah
and um yeah there was people walking out
and about in what looks like the
cleanest air in the world oh it's like
the yeah you can like yeah it's the best
purest air on the planet and yeah people
still outdoor uh masking which I don't
know I I did reflect on this a little
bit like how I feel now about like
someone in a car on their own or
something you know when people wore
masks in cars on their own or someone
out and about in fresh a at this stage
of post-pandemic like [__] noncase
risk it does make me think people who
were so vehement against any masking
ever like no one should ever have to do
it it's like well maybe just my judgment
of the situation is that my sensitivity
needed it to be a few years later yeah
whereas they were like even now in the
midst of it even though we don't know it
that's like how and I mean do what you
want you know like this is America like
that's the most ethos of this country is
it's more like do if you want to wear a
mask in a car like that's your right
it's the problem was when there were
saying you have to do it and then people
are like okay well that's very much
unamerican you know to to make anybody
do anything but I mean have you spent
any time in Asia yeah a little bit not
since Co but so they've been you know
like I I traveled in Asia 15 years ago
and you know you'd walk around
everybody's wearing masks yeah that was
for uh air quality and stuff right well
air quality and I think they had had
some kind of smaller pandemics and they
just are generally and I look I do think
if you are very uh
like strict about it and you know proper
I'm sure it does somewhat lower your uh
risk of getting ill to some degree you
could play a pretty good game I just
don't care that much you could play
quite a good we actually did play a
pretty good game of Asian or covid MH
which is like why are they wearing the
mask is it because of like historical
air quality yeah or is it because of Co
yeah I heard in Thailand actually
someone explained to me that some people
cuz they wear these really big masks
that go like literally here and it's
because they their class system like
many other places is the more tanned you
are the lower class the lower class you
are so it's and skin whitening is huge
in Thailand dude I went to Thailand I
saw this the girls that worked at the
front of the uh restaurants the
secretaries for like offices for massage
places all of that stuff would have like
lighter skin but you can see there's a
line here and it's it just completely
drove home how culturally inculcated I
was in the UK for me to look at that and
say how strange like purposefully making
your skin lighter because people who
work in the fields are seen as like
Indigent laborers that means that
they're of lower status the people who
have white color jobs that work in
indoors they don't get taned how silly
that you would try and lighten your skin
I go back to Newcastle upon the place
where the British version of Jersey Shaw
was filmed Jordi Shaw to see girls make
their faces [__] orange to like give
the appearance of you know I spend time
outside and I can go to May whenever I
want and it's the exact same but in
Reverse yeah that that's pretty funny
and I just didn't see it I was like ah
how strange as I go back to Newcastle to
get caked in fake T right I guess it's
the quickest way to Signal something
right is just your visually like you
it's it's the equivalent of wearing like
a Rolex you know but for such a strange
Quirk I'll never forget one of my
friends who's a DJ told me this story
with kind of the uh you say like
cultural thermometer of what you're used
to anchoring off and what you actually
uh you go to somewhere new and
everything's upside down [__] Bar's
being turned around he went and played a
gig DJ Gig in South America he's a DJ he
parties he wanted some cocaine he was
like I'm me like [__] Ecuador or
Argentina or Columbia or some [__] he's
like I'm [__] the source is here like
the the Fountain of cocaine is here so
he goes to the promoter and he's like
can you get me some cocaine and he
looked at him I was like are you sure
it's like yes I would like some cocaine
he's like [__] hell man I mean like I
can get you some but and he was thinking
oh God like maybe there's going to be
police maybe there's like a the the um
prison sentences for it are really high
or it's like very you know we're going
to involve ourselves in some gang stuff
what it turned out was that people who
do cocaine in these areas it's seen as
super dirty it's seen as a scummy drug
but uh was it 3tb or something what's
that 2cb yes 2cb 3 the pink the the pink
stuff 2cb yeah 2cb is seen as the high
Clash sh because it's so hard to get a
hold of down there so he the drug is the
same and in fact probably of way better
quality than the stepped on [__] that
you'll buy Street in [__] new yor
question but because the cultural
position like the map of that particular
terrain was like this is easy and cheap
to get so it just completely shows that
the value of the thing is not intrinsic
of the thing it is the difficulty of
acquisition and the price yeah like 2cb
is like it's like hot have you ever seen
it it's hot pink like it's this weird
thing you're like oh God yeah so yeah I
don't know it's uh I had this guy on my
Callin show Yan gorillo if you ever
heard of him I do you know him yeah yeah
a few weeks he's amazing I was talking
to him and he's uh like a narco reporter
in Mexico or whatever and he was saying
actually like yeah cocaine is it's like
popular but it's not the the most
popular drug is actually I think meth
right now and and they have no issues
because all the fentol comes over the
Border but they have like no issues with
fentanyl there Douglas Murray went to
this place in Philadelphia have you
heard of Tran
yeah yeah Tran's like fentanyl's
fentanyl mhm it's for people like like
makes your like skin peel and just
people yeah like bits if you drop off
it's like leprosy in a drug yeah and um
yeah he went to this place in
Philadelphia and filmed this I'm on like
a campaign to get Douglas Murray uh
acquired by the daily wire I sat down
with Jeremy boring the CEO and I was
like dude you need to acquire uh Douglas
Murray so anyway [__] Jeremy for
watching Go and Do It um but Douglas
went and filmed this thing he hasn't
released it yet uh but yeah he went to
Philadelphia and apparently like Tran
has just taken over yeah taken over the
city so like fentanyl or heroin not
enough fentanyl not enough and then
there's car fentanyl yeah which is like
even more potent fentanyl Fentanyl and
then this is like car fentanyl's car
fentanyl Tran yeah I mean it's sad that
people are yeah I don't know to get to
the point where you kind of that's what
you need like even fentel is not doing
it for you [__] that would normal man on
the head of a pin is not enough for you
well you you do de velop a massive
tolerance I I had a friend of mine who's
a doctor in um Vancouver British
Columbia and they have they have a big
drug problem there and they've
decriminalized all drugs and she was
telling because I was asking about the
fentanyl thing she's like yeah the thing
is with fentol is heroin users can't get
heroin or sometimes it's actually vice
versa where where people go to heroin
actually because it might be a little uh
cheaper I can't remember but anyways she
says you know they use so much
fentanyl that they just you you develop
a massive tolerance to it like [__]
passively smoking trying to get high
nicotine kind of but it yeah but but the
you just you keep building up this
tolerance so the people who actually die
from fentanyl are the ones who have
never ingested it and it gets
cross-contaminated and so they have no
uh have you heard of spice is spice a
thing over here spice is like it's like
fake weed or something yes yes yes so I
watch a lot of cops the show Cops it's
like a guilty pleasure of mine and it's
actually sad because a lot of episodes
like segments in cops is they're like
arresting someone for Spike
I'm like why is this even illegal and
the problem is because weed's illegal
it's all in Florida like you always see
people get arrested for spice in Florida
and I guess spice was like recently
criminalized but it wasn't always
because I guess it's it like you know it
popped up and then they take some time
to make it legal but so people are
forced to take it because they can't
smoke weed which is harmless essentially
like I mean not harmless but relatively
on the scale of drugs it is you know
like sure it'll it it might give some
bad habits or whatever but you know
relatively forcing people to smoke spice
and then they're getting arrested for
spice yeah there's a I think the way it
works may be wrong with this I'm me
[__] spice expert but I'm pretty sure
that it it is in a spray bottle and that
you spray the whatever the stuff is that
you smoke with this particular solution
but I remember watching this thing on
YouTube and this guy is wearing
literally wearing like three pairs of
[__] surgical gloves because if even
a tiny bit of it at this you know and
he's like there're spraying at a
distance like a [__] plant sprayer
and he's like if you even got a little
bit of this on you at that concentrate
it' be like you know LSD it would just
completely destroy you um it's super
dangerous so yeah it's just this that's
one of the things I wish I'd brought it
up with Jeremy actually um but that's
one of the things that I would criticize
the like the right
for this obsession with more newsworthy
like sexy stories like stuff to do with
like trans books in schools and all the
rest of this [__] it's like the fentanyl
problem seems like like a really big
deal that's just killing people [__]
straight away but I'm not really hearing
anyone on the left or the right really
talk about that it's just like yeah it's
one of those push it under the rug yeah
I think so I think it's one of those
things where uh you know you can't like
you don't stop that problem by
enforcement right it's like you almost
have to stop the people who wanted which
is you know the chicken in the egg War
on Drugs thing fix the [__] you know
like there's no way that you can stop
every like you know um truck that comes
into the United States from Mexico it's
impossible they can they they can maybe
stop like even search 10% of them and
the problem with fentanyl is is you need
like a thing this big to kill 10 million
people yeah because it's so concentrated
it's so concentrated right so is it is
it right that it's supposed to be China
that produces almost all China this is
what Y and gorillo told me they produce
the
precursor so there's like a precursor
that Acquired and then so what happens
is China and and but these are like um
above the water like above board you
know like just legitimate comp
pharmaceutical companies who make this
precursor and and then um Mexican
cartels are essentially acquiring it so
presumably that precursor is even more
concentrated so you need even less of
that yeah I don't know if that's how it
works if it's specifically a
concentrated form or just it's just one
of the ingredients that on its own is I
don't think is necessarily toxic or
maybe it is but it's not fentanyl on its
own but if you get that one precursor
and then you add it to this you know
essentially like a a recipe I guess you
know I'm no expert on this but that's
what yeah essentially yeah but so and
then he I can't remember exactly what he
told me but something along the lines of
like they had like you know the DEA
tried to do some things with these
Chinese companies and then kind of like
they're they're unable to really stop
them because it's I don't know it's it's
some sort of and I think China says you
know we'll try and crack down on these
but again they're they're not
technically illegal because fentol is
used by hospitals and you know like if
you have some massive surgery they will
give you some of these things yes as
painkillers like they are like real
painkillers but like anything they get
abused so did you see Kim Jong-un wiping
away tears as he asked North Korean
women to have more children yeah and
then the funniest thing is they're all
in the audience and they're all the
moment the moment one tier they're all
just
like
they want to get in trouble yeah uh
assessments show that the fertility rate
in North Korea has been falling for a
decade amid increasing concerns within
families over lots of money being needed
to raise children and food North Korean
leader Kim Jong-un appeared to wipe away
tears as he urged women to Halt a
decline in the country's Birthright Mr
Kim was seen dabbing his eyes with a
handkerchief in a rare moment of emotion
as he addressed the national mothers
meeting in Pyongyang the Hyundai
Institute report said that North Korea's
population was expected to shrink
starting in
2034 yeah that's uh I I don't know I
don't know what their demographic
situation is like [__] dude the South
Korea I think is at 0.6 or 0.8 as a
birth rate 2.1 is replacement 2.1 is
replacement yeah and they for every
hundred South Koreans alive right now
there will be four great-grandchildren
it's a 96% Extinction rate over the next
100 years [__] crazy country that's
above 2.1 yes um so like funnily enough
the highest on the planet Chad Chad yeah
yeah just like the because they're
Chads nice um no yeah that's the highest
but even uh subsaharan Africa every 15
years the number of children that each
mother has is decreasing by one so it's
I think it's about seven now and then in
15 years it'll be six and then in 15
years it'll be five and 15 years it'll
be four and some the average family size
is seven children at the moment yeah wow
um I don't know whether that is per
woman or per mother because that's
different there are some women who don't
have kids and if you do that if you
actually look at that number in America
the number is still the same as it's
always been it's like 2.3 mothers have
about 2.3 children or 2.5 children or
something like that it's the nonm
mothers that is increasing women that
have zero if you have one you end up
having like two and a half but if you
have none you keep having n yeah you
keep having done yeah um so yeah dude
that whole Birthright thing but that's
that's one of the things that um do you
know Pete Zion you seen that dude no
it's like a geopolitics guy I had him on
the show a little while ago he did Rogan
too and um China's population's going to
half basically over the next like that's
so funny that they had their one child
policy [__] it and it was such a
disaster but at the time it seemed like
such a necessary great idea and then it
was like maybe one of the most
short-sighted things because you can't
just like undo that you don't snap your
fingers and go okay back to back to CH
or however many you want you're like no
the damage from that policy is 100 years
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's wild well I
mean the choice
between uh like famine now or like
Extinction later yeah is I don't know
like I guess yeah yeah but uh yeah there
CU they're they have I mean seems like
everybody has huge demographic issues I
guess America English speaking Western
countries though can fix that with just
immigration whereas China is probably a
tougher place to immigrate yeah they can
but I mean that's just kind of kicking
the can down the road if you have like a
total global population like this which
is ultimately what matters and you just
start trying to [__] move chess
pieces around so you don't get any more
chess pieces right that that is true
yeah I don't um because I had a this is
total conspiracy theory based on nothing
but when roie Wade got repealed that was
that my conspiracy brain was like
they're doing that because you know they
gave America The the choice to have more
that fertility to have more kids and
they go you're you're not having more
kids so we're just going to force it on
you and we don't care what like how they
come in or what they just we need bodies
the additional conspiracy theory on top
of that which I heard someone give me
was who are the people that are the
least able if you restrict access to
abortion who are the people that are
least able to skirt around the rules the
poor people that become the worker
drones exactly so it's just we need some
more [__] Blue Collar like widget
yeah exactly and at the end of the day
the way the economy is set up is it's
essentially like I don't want to say
like a pyramid scheme but it kind of is
like it just it requires more people
like the way that you know having steady
like 2% growth every year that they aim
for and you know like you just you need
more growth that's all they that's
that's how the whole game is set up is
just more people right they don't care
like I mean obviously to agree you want
which people but you just need more
people I I need to learn I've watched so
many different explainers about how the
global
like currency Finance system and this
embedded growth obligation and
debt-based financing and like if you
continue to kind of grow it then it's
almost like a Ponzi scheme within itself
where no one realizes that the new money
is like feeding the old debt well kind
of and just new new like you know real
estate for example like you just they
always want to be building more and
putting people in those things and
putting people in those new houses they
don't ever you don't ever want a
scenario where there's just like those
Chinese ghost towns you know like and
and that's how they kind of set
everything up so they're just kind of
slowly just building more things and
they need people to take those things
watching all of these [__] things
dude I still kind of don't fully
understand how it works I need I should
probably just bring someone on show just
more people more more people means they
need somewhere to live and they consume
more they buy more stuff like you know
that's that's you know again some
theories about why they're opening up
the southern border is they're just like
those people are still regardless of how
you feel about it and people are people
they're still people and they're still
consumers they still have to buy toilet
paper and they have to eat and they have
to get around and you know most of them
uh you know some people are very
uncharitable I'm not most of them will
try and work and they want to work
obviously some because a lot of people
are like Oh They'll just you know live
off the government te kind of thing that
I think that's a very small percentage
of those people most of those people
just want a better life if I was in
their position I would do the exact same
thing if I lived in some Central
American country with 50% unemployment
rate and I I knew that I mean it's crazy
cuz they're not even all Central
Southern Americans they're coming from
all CH China whatever and you know if I
was in their position I'd probably do
the same thing dude have you heard what
happens if you're a Cuban and you want
to like Escape Cuba oh crazy so we have
a mutual friend who did a film event of
some kind in Canada I think and told me
this story so he did this one thing and
then his brother did a different thing
I'm pretty sure he filmed the whole
filmed the the entirety of this like
[__] Journey that he was on and I was
like hang in a [__] second like this
is like seeking Asylum from a war
stricken country I didn't realize that
Cuba it sounds so stupid I didn't
realize that Cuba was like a place that
first off you're kind of not allowed to
leave doesn't want you to leave and
communist country that's every communist
country is you're not allowed to leave
but you've got the US has basically got
this rule where if you come from
presumably Venezuela as well and also
maybe China although I don't know yeah
it's just like hey we'll give you Asylum
don't don't worry and um yeah this guy
told me so he did this thing where he
snuck out at 4 in the morning from some
event and it was literally like a game
of chicken so he was leading this team
of people maybe they were um like
videography team or something like that
and I think he maybe had a partner that
was with him and he knew because he was
the leader that if anybody else left the
party that he was a part of he would be
culpable mhm so he was like I'm just
going to [__] go before anyone else
does so Game Theory kind of exactly it's
prison's dilemma and him and his uh
partner leave at 4:00 a.m. in the
morning like sneakily like pack their
stuff get out hitch hike their way blah
blah blah do all of this [__] needly get
stopped get to the American Border hey
we're from Cuba yeah uh give us Asylum
and then his brother does the same thing
but travels like by land from [__]
Cuba through Guatemala through Biz
through like [__] well there's the
whole thing they all just cuz it's only
like 60 miles from from Miami right Cuba
from is is only 6 oh it's so close that
that's so like there's all these umit on
it there's all these baseball players
because Cuba's like has some of the best
baseball players in the world and Garcia
is he Cuban uh I think so yeah yeah yeah
exactly the guy on the Rangers exactly
and they they've had you know endless
amounts of good players but they're not
allowed to leave but some of them are
like if I could just get 60 miles like
uh L du who used to play for the Yankees
uh I can't remember or I think his name
is Orlando Hernandez in like the '90s
but he just like you know dead of night
they hop on like a make rickety raft
kind of like you know and they get over
and if you can just get to shore there's
a $5 million baseball contract waiting
for you that 50 100 million for some of
these guys some of these guys are like
instantly you know some of the top
players in the league but there there's
and you know they do like the World
Baseball Classic stuff where Cuba Fields
a team and there's always you know same
with like Olympics and there's always
like a couple guys who just defect right
but the problem is is that there's you
know your family is still in Cuba and so
now you like they probably have some
issues it's probably like a a thing of
like shame to a degree well the North
Korean thing is if you break the rules
it's not just you and your family that
gets persecuted it's like eight
generations of your family they're extra
condemn your [__] future great great
great great granddaughter to being a
like a [__] minor or something yeah
like my parents are from Russia and uh
like when my parents left my mom's dad
was in like the Communist Party in in
Russia you know like this is in the 70s
and when she left he got kicked
out like they gave him the boot and he
was like a good like you know communist
you know he was like he fought in the
Red Army against the Nazis all that
stuff like he was like a war hero and
then they were just like well you know
you did a bad job raising your child col
punishment thing is one hell of a yeah
like a a
motivator yeah it's it's it's [__]
Wildman do you see this undercover video
shows PornHub employees want porn to
steer young people's sexual I saw you
know what I saw I saw that trending I
didn't actually watch the video so it's
just like a kind of project Veritas type
thing exactly like that yeah employees
of pornhub's parent company were caught
on camera touting the benefits of
underage kids watching pornography and
even suggesting that making videos of
transgender identifying people engaging
in sex could help young people figure
out their sexuality according to a new
video released exclusively on the
Michael nolles show on Wednesday
employee Dylan rice a senior script
writer at the company
script they still do that I don't know
they seen arguing that pornography usage
could be beneficial for preens let's say
you're 12 years old you're still
figuring out your sexuality maybe even
your gender wouldn't it be helpful to
see a celebration but not just but maybe
just a normalization of something that
you think is what you want rice has seen
saying rice went on to specifically
reference a pornography sit centered
around transgender individuals remarking
let's say I was 12 and I saw trans
Angels it would help me figure out what
I do like and what I don't
like um
I mean I guess I I don't I'm not sure
like you know I I I haven't gone through
every category of on the porn websites
but I imagine there's quite something
for everybody there do you know what
India the second most popular type of
porn in India is no
breastfeeding breastfeeding porn dude
it's so strange so this is from uh Seth
Steven dz's book um uh everybody lies
and he his argument was basically you
tell Google things that you don't tell
yourself or your journal or your partner
because it's what do you want not what
do you think about like writing and
reflecting on yeah and he looked at
PornHub data and it's just breastfeeding
porn isn't big anywhere it's not even
big in like surrounding countries
whatever the [__] around India uh it's
not big Indian people Indian men
specifically just seem to [__] love
breastfeeding porn weird yeah and is
there any uh Theory as to why he gave me
like some because cows are sacred oh wow
this is like deep yeah it's like some
[__] religious symbolism yeah I don't
know um but yeah this I I don't know
like I've been thinking this more and
more about the um some of the expose
[__] that we see online there was a a
screen grab of maybe a Tinder
conversation or a dating conversation
that went Mega hyper hyper viral of a
guy saying that he wanted a traditional
wife and the woman saying that's really
great cuz that's what I want too
and then he accused her of being a gold
digger because she said that she would
stay at home and it's like early days
dating or whatever but it just like
reading it seemed
so not the way that people text there
was unnecessary Exposition about the
fact that they went for dinner last
night and I knew that I shouldn't have
done that and she was like what do you
mean I paid for the bill at dinner last
night and it was like you think it's
fake this just feels a little bit clunky
yeah that seemed like a [__] false
flag but the same thing with like some
of the [__] secret camera [__] and
also the same for on Street interviews
like the on Street interviews the ones
that make these compilations like what
what didn't make it like how many people
said I'm just really looking for someone
that kind of respects me and R that's
not going viral no yeah it's always it's
always the worst stuff you know and yeah
you don't know like that like it could
be legitimately we talked to a thousand
people two of them said the worst [__]
you've ever heard of and that's the only
one that's interesting I guess it's this
weird combination of is it legit so is
is what you're seeing contrived made up
like that set of screenshots that I
think was and okay let's say that that's
not was this an unfair representation of
what most people saw and then what does
what they said actually mean is what
they're saying what they meant to say
and is that actually how they're going
to show up in their life it's edited
like oh man dude like it every time I
think about it I know it's like flogging
a dead horse about like oh it's so hard
to work out what the facts are and you
people can't even agree on what the word
truth means any oh we We can't agree on
anything anymore like it's wild it's
it's insane every argument now is just
everybody talking past each other it
everybody almost seems like when they're
arguing there seems like there might be
some resolution like everybody feels
like someone be like they say the point
everybody goes all right yeah yeah okay
we we' we've sorted it out but it's not
everybody is just you're on your side
and that's that's it it's that's uh
everybody's you know just picks a side
and then they're staying on that side
it's very rare I think right now where
people's minds are changed when was the
last time I keep thinking about this on
Twitter no one ever actually breaks the
fourth wall on Twitter and says hey that
was out of order like you can't say that
it's always this like clapback satirical
game of tennis where you're trying to be
Wittier or more cutting than what the
last person said and it's all like
sardonic passive aggressive like quote
[__] subtweeting what the last person
said it's never someone like just going
like hey hey that's out of order you
don't get to say that no one actually
[__] treats it like an actual
conversation no no no know I mean you
know what the closest I've seen to some
uh which was like brought me so much joy
I thought it was the funniest thing to
to some sort of argument that resolved
was in uh I posted this video about
because since the it's been going on for
a while it used to be like really you
know dark web kind of uh stuff like
white supremacist stuff but these charts
of how Jews that are representation of
Jews and things like in I don't know if
you've seen it they'll be like it'll say
like all the Jews in politics or the
media or whatever and these giant charts
remember Kanye he he held up that he had
his thing about the the spreadsheet so
then once the war started all these
anti-israel people were like look at all
these Jews that are and so then I made
this sketch and it was the guy that
researches how many Jews are in things
and I'm like this very just like
autistic just like I just like knowing
how many Jews there are and things and I
just make these lists or whatever of
Jews there are and things and it went
like really viral and then in the
comments was this guy and he like like
he goes what's so funny like you know
why because essentially a guy is like
who had his list and then he goes he
goes my list is uh he goes here's and he
had a a Drive Link of a public list that
he made and then he started getting in
an argument with another guy who's like
I have a list and my list is actually
better it's it's more thorough and then
they were like in the comments going
back andth with each other about whose
list of Jews dick measuring compet
circumcised dick measuring but it was
their it was they were just like who's
has a more uh accurate list of Jews that
are represented in things and then they
were arguing and then they finally the
one guy goes you know what I looked at
yours and yours is actually better than
mine and uh and they kind of like became
friends oh my God it was and I was like
oh my God you watched a buring Brom man
comment over yeah in my comments I I
screenshotted it all cuz I thought it
was the funni thing and they they
essentially started off as enemies dude
it's been a [__] rough year for Jews
this year like honestly like between
Kanye and [__] Middle East Well
everybody's so surprised about the the
what's going on now with the Jewish
stuff but uh I saw it firsthand with the
Kanye stuff because when the Kanye thing
you know I was commenting on that and
you know like I was making sketches
around that and so I would see go on
YouTube on on and it was you know pretty
much all in favor of Kanye so then so I
was not surprised now people are like
what the what's going on people don't
like Jews huh I'm like yeah yeah I've
seen that for that's kind of been been
bubbling up I think that's always kind
of under the surface literally for the
last 3,000 years but I don't have my
head at my ass that much like I I
noticed Trends and I I pay attention to
[__] as best I can and I had no [__]
idea that there was this much latent
anti-Semitism yeah it's just it's kind
of it's it's like herpes
it's like a cultural herpes where it
just it has these outbreaks like these
flare ups you know and then it kind of
like goes away and then it kind of
flares up again and then yeah it is
really weird to see CU I have some
friends who who kind of don't realize
because I get it because I comment on
this stuff a lot a lot of the sketches I
make are like around this stuff like the
ones I personally make not with like
Ryan and uh yeah and then like some of
the you see like insane
comments but I mean I don't know well I
mean people have started to use
the only thing I can do is just make fun
of it there's no you know it's the only
even the episode I did with Peterson a
couple of weeks ago there was a bunch of
comments calling him Juden Juden
peterstein
[Laughter]
yeah I love it problem is I'm like yeah
I I find it so funny you know I think a
lot of Jews are uh don't find it funny
they're like this is more serious and
you know guess that could be determined
I sometimes joke about it where uh I
make too much fun of this stuff and then
I'm you know getting put on a train and
I go ah I made too much fun of that I
should have taken that more
seriously Alex Jones tells Tucker
Carlson that President Biden walks
around the the White House naked drugged
on amphetamines and benzos as Elon Musk
says that he's considering allowing uh
Alex Jones back on X yeah yeah that I
mean I don't I I don't know about that I
mean I suppose it's possible well we've
everyone's been they should let him back
on though everyone's been uh speculating
for quite a while about what they've had
to pump Biden with in order to roll him
out on stage yeah you know like some uh
like sort of punch drunk WWE star like
Hulk Hogan coming back for another and
you like a CT is all shot in the knee
I'm gonna get some like [__] opioids
for my spine and chiropractor is gonna
come in and do this thing I yeah I don't
know he uh he seems to have his moments
for sure where he's better and when like
sometimes you'll see him talking and you
go oh he seems okay right now but then
sometimes but I I I mean I kind of joke
about it he's the only 81-year-old who
we treat poorly like this like if he was
not like a civilian like we would
remember when he fell off his bike and
everybody's like that [__] idiot fell
off his bike you're like he's an old man
yeah you'd pick him up and be like yeah
like are you okay yeah are you okay like
can we get you and now we're just like
he fell off his bike but I guess when
you're the most powerful person in the
world there's a that's so right a higher
standard that's so right like everyone's
mean to old people he's like a sweet old
man that being said not sweet maybe not
sweet but yeah I think uh someone
highlighted that if Trump gets in office
next year he will be older than when
Biden got in office I believe yeah Trump
looks older does he yeah I haven't seen
him
recently showing the old age on the face
uh he yeah he looks I mean again I don't
know what the kind of curve is like the
Aging curve when I i' I've seen some
people say it's almost closer to a step
function yeah like you just like your
age kind of like it kind of really hits
you yeah it really hits you cuz he does
seem more than four years older than he
was four years ago the uh well there's
that photo that famous photo of Obama
right like before and after Presidency
it's every president that [__] ages you
I I mean when you have to press a button
and kill a
village it has to take a toll on you do
you know how they do the um like [__]
uh nuclear football you know how that
thing works no I found out from this guy
it's so [__] fascinating so
there's 130 missile silos ibcm nuclear
missile silos all around the states
right at each one of those at all times
there are two officers and both of the
officers have keys around their
neck now what you would think would
happen is there's a nuclear football
that goes with the president and that
it's got a special piece of paper that
they snap in like a wax seal they snap
that they pull it apart there's a piece
of paper inside that's got a code they
enter the code that then triggers The
Silo the people get the code enter the
code turn the keys at the same time the
reason you have two people is so that
one is accountable to the other and so
that one person can't do it on their own
but also that you don't get I think it's
called like willing Des centers or
something so that one it's like there's
pressure right it's like no dude this is
your job like we've got to do the thing
but obviously one of the problems that
you have with doing it that way is if
you're [__] if you're the guy that
The Silo comes off both of you can be
nervous about doing it we about I'm
about to [__] turn the key and kill
like God like thousands of people or
something so every 45 minutes or so
every single Silo around the entire us
has one of these things happen really
all of them and then the guys get their
keys put them in turn them enter the
like enter the code press the [__]
button and then they go back so they
what yeah every less than it's like
around about every single hour and I
think they're on 8 hour shifts and
there's like whatever the Bunches of
people so 24 hours a day 365 this is
happening and they always go off it goes
off all the time and they don't know if
it's real or if it's another one of the
drills yeah it's just a drill and they
just have to and the reason that they do
that is when it does happen if it does
happen when it's real it's just you've
been programmed it's like this is part
yeah just like but you have heard the
stories from Russia it's the opposite
there so it's the most junior members of
staff that do the or some of the most
Junior Intelligence Officers that have
the keys because it's kind of a bit of a
dry job it's like put the key and turn
it press the button BL whatever but in
Russia it's the opposite it's the most
senior members of Staff but you'll
remember like there's like three times
that we've come basically super close to
nuclear war and oh it turned out to be
like pieces of foil that were in the sky
or like the glint of birds or something
or some misreading on the there was a
submarine one inre where they uh lost
contact and they they basically had some
sort of order like I can't remember the
exact story I think I heard it on Coast
to Coast or something but it's like a
famous like a US submarine they they
lost full contact and essentially like
the protocol was that they believed that
they were under nuclear attack and they
had to do it and then some guy willing
to Center he overrode he goes no we're
not doing it and then he was right and
he so had he not been they would have
just accidentally La start so that that
happened like I think at least two or
three times in Russia but this in the US
this is the final like [__] kicker
that I learned from this dude and he
said that
um not only is it all of them happening
almost all the time 24 hours a day 365
they don't know if it's real or if it's
fake but all of them are part of one
network so all it takes is for one pair
of people to enter the code and they all
fire and they'll fire whichever one
needs because they're all pointing at
different places yeah like I can be in
[__] Iowa and the Wisconsin [__]
thing goes off even if so you need like
one pair of people out of 130 pairs of
people who also have the accountability
of each other and also don't know if
it's real or if it's fake and then I
guess just one day if it ever happens
one day you're just going to [__]
like put the code in and then
here oh my be
like that's insane y holy [__] so
[__] wild that's wild I had no idea I
always thought it was just the president
goes enters the thing and go press
literally I you just open a briefcase
there's a button you go whack whack and
no [__] cool probably better though
that way what have you reflected on
about sort of Matt R Fallout have you
thought about this much you know
honestly I feel like I I know a guy who
uh who like opens for him and you know
he has a unique situation because his
audience one he got famous super fast
his audience is all women right it's
like 90 it's the opposite of our
audience like literally it's like all
women and uh I think when this stuff
like it was a basic joke it wasn't
anything that crazy but I think he Matt
r probably wants to be like I just want
to be a comedian for everyone so I I
think he kind of leaned into this
controversy because it allowed him to
kind of just um shave off a bit of the
audience yeah you go I'm going to get
rid of the 10% of the most annoying
audience that uh just kind of you know
it's maybe a little fair weather and you
know I don't want to Cave to their
demands I just want to do what I want
and he might have been able to replace
those 10% with a new 10% of guys so net
net it probably is better move so that's
kind of how I read it he's just like
look I'm a comic I'm not trying to cater
to a specific audience do you think that
that playing it that way cuz he then
posted like the Instagram story of the
special needs help yeah yeah yeah he's
just trying to be like that's just comic
stuff do you think that that's given him
or will give him more legitimacy in like
the comedy world not that he doesn't
already have it but yeah uh I mean I
don't think he needs like legitimately P
like you know he's sells 5,000 tickets a
night like that's legitimate enough yeah
that's legitimate enough I think he just
wants maybe to not be pigeon hold and
nobody really does I think as a comedian
so I think he he just wants to say Hey
you know I'm not like some just handsome
dude who's not doing jokes you know I
can be funny just like another comedian
would which I think was probably a smart
move for him I think I told and then you
get also just all the people complaining
about you and it just raises your
profile because you know he was on TMZ
everybody's like oh this guy so I'm sure
lots of people didn't even know who he
was yeah yeah well I think Rogan said
his show has never had as many plays as
when CNN was featuring him exactly yeah
so the the striesand effect if you use
it right it can be pretty powerful and
there you know it's saying but there is
really no no negative publicity you know
like as long as you're not doing
something like criminal I suppose but
yeah I told you about this last night
but um Sam Harris talks about digital
leprosy yeah yeah yeah but this is
almost like um uh purposeful leprosy or
like elected leprosy so Sam's Point
being that he gets
into different furors and and and
debates or whatever on Twitter but now
doesn't have Twitter so bits of his
audience might be mad at him and be
leaving but because he's not there he
doesn't notice it like a leopard like
the fingers fall off and the [__] falls
off and they're like like I didn't feel
it but I wonder whether um Matt in some
regards almost was like oh this is my
opportunity to Cull some Barnacles off
the bottom of the ship I don't want uh
so if I lean into this even more I'll
get rid of like a little bit of more
Barnacles too and I mean what's supposed
to do apologize for a joke like there's
that is like the number one rule of
Comedy you do not apologize for your
jokes I asked to Schultz this last year
do you think that there are is there
such a thing as a joke that shouldn't be
told I mean if it constantly
bombs I mean that's the only thing is it
funny is it funny and is it not funny I
you know obviously that that's like the
starting point is is it funny or is it
not funny if you tell a joke and it
constantly bombs and you go yeah don't
tell that joke then you can get into you
know more like uh craft kind of stuff
where you say hey is this the is this a
good joke because there's bad jokes that
do well that make people laugh and there
may be cheap jokes or whatever then you
can start getting into that but you know
every comic has they have to make those
decisions for themselves that's exactly
what Schult said yeah literally he was
like I I said is there a joke that
shouldn't be told and he said is it
funny and I was like yes he said
tell it yeah if it's a funny joke you're
allowed to tell it yeah exactly you're
allowed to tell it and then if you want
to say like you know some every comic
sometimes will come up with a joke and
then you tell it and it kills you go
feels kind of cheap you know for
whatever reason what's like a it might
even be yeah it might be icky because
it's just like it's kind of
hacky what's like an example of
something like just like what were we
talking about with the you know you're
just Comics are talking about their
lives and then you know you talk about
your life like air it was the airplane
stuff going through the airport
sometimes or whatever you some be like
ah it's like that's a funny joke but you
know maybe it's not the best take on it
Biden falling off a bike joke or
something kind of or I mean I'll tell
you what uh because comedy has shifted
because of um the speed at which it used
to be like a lot of comedians would put
out a new special every like four years
kind of thing and uh now it's a little
quicker because in order to tour and
just the amount amount of comedians but
a lot of comics will comment on the same
stuff like you know Jeffrey dmer show
came out and then there's 10 comedians
you know you might be the first but then
eventually everyone's everybody's doing
Jeffrey dber bits and then you got to be
like okay do I have the best Jeffrey
dber bit or am I at least there's like
it's almost like an arms race to get it
out there to be like at least I'm the
first one to get it out there because
you definitely don't want to be the guy
with the special with you know the 10th
Jeffrey dmer bit uh right but
everybody's watching the same stuff
right now like and all these things are
the biggest cult Cal things you know so
if you want to comment on the thing that
everybody is seeing uh I mean the
classic thing would be Trump with late
night you know it just it became so
trite and it ruined these comedians it
literally like ruined their brains you
know they were constantly just all they
could talk about was Trump and it was uh
and it was dishonest how they were
talking about it and people kind of you
know at first people were like yeah and
then even people on the left were like
okay this is this is just hack tack yeah
yeah did we were talking um last night
about this sort of Fallout from late
night show hosts trying to come and do
less scripted more just banter stuff and
you kind of get to see like who's
swimming naked there as well they're all
swimming I mean it was for that Strike
Force 5 thing that they did the five uh
late night host during the strike and uh
I watched it it was terrible it was well
it was literally a zoom call between
Five Guys they had nothing prepared they
just and you know they the very classic
like they told you know Steven coar was
telling some story about some famous
dictator's pants that he had and like
some famous I can't remember but like
some dictator like dated his mom or
something in like the 60s Mia or some
[__] yeah and he's like I have his
pants and then they tell some story
about like buying I saw Sammy Davis Jr
Jimmy Kimmel's like yeah I saw Sammy
Davis Jr like a store okay yeah and it's
just like it's just so Bal and mundane
and you know they you can they're like
yeah these the crazy thing is these guys
have all 20
Riders and the 20 Riders still are not
cranking out much you think's the future
what's the what's the future of Comedy
from where you're seeing like one of the
trends you've seen is that specials are
having to be paced up more quickly yeah
for sure Lou Louie was kind of the first
guy who pressed the accelerator but now
you know yeah you have to especially if
you're talking about certain things it
just gets stale so you either put it out
or you just can do it uh uh and then
stop doing it which is not is there a is
there a delicate balance between showing
enough of what you're working on that a
good jokes on Instagram or Tik Tok or
whatever to be able to sell tickets for
your shows versus not releasing your
entire special in 45 second chunks in
advance of the special yeah yeah and you
know what sometimes this is kind of a
newer thing where a a lot of comics will
you know when they go on the road
they'll have a a little time devoted to
just kind of stuff that's in the news
and they're not the most polished jokes
but because they're referencing
something so current they actually will
hit well and then you can release those
cuz those don't actually really make the
act right those will like like Mark no
and samarel does a good job of that Ryan
does a good job of that um but yeah
they'll just kind of like just it's
almost like how we comment on something
on a podcast you know oh this [__]
happened Britney Spear you see that
video Brit and you know you're not
really it's not good enough where you're
like this isn't going to make isn't
going to be a part of the special yeah
it's not going to be a part of the
special but we can talk about this today
and this one weekend at this show and
then I'll clip this I'll film this and
put it out and so you kind of what else
what else is happening in in the world
of like ComEd comedy I mean it's like
it's really funny me and Ryan were
talking about how a lot of uh comedians
are now like like like actor like the
actual celebrities are now becoming
podcasters essentially because that
whole world is fragmenting I don't you
know we're not really in it to be honest
but that whole world of Comedy is is
getting uh very fragmented like you know
our the people who are fans of us I
can't imagine they you know they don't
watch late night they don't really I
don't even know what comedies are on
like I don't know what a comedy show is
on right
now big bang no it's been off so that so
so funny we talked about that it's been
cancelled for like seven years or
something it never watch if you walk
around New York right now you'd feel
like it was no no no they have they're
like the buses and taxis have all ads
for it because that's what's going on
with comedy where they're promoting a
show that's been canell for seven years
like it's a show that's on because
there's no good shows that are on I know
there's always sunny and Philadelphia's
on uh which is like all the good shows
comedy wise are the shows that have been
on for 15 years like South Park zo Sunny
Philadelphia but in terms of new
comedies it's there there's and I get it
there's you know you don't want to take
these risks there's a disincentive to
comedic risk- taking because of you know
the climate I guess so and they don't
and and you know the comedies that come
out are just the most vanilla like kind
of mundane [__] and no I wonder whether
the distance because South Park's
Illustrated I wonder whether the
distance that the people who make it
have from the like actors that make the
ACT a front and center on the TV show
wonder if that's giving them a little
bit more longevity I I I just think that
they're such a money maker and you know
like Comedy Central like for example
Comedy Central doesn't make anything
anymore they they just don't like I I
couldn't tell you what they make they
just air reruns of their uh properties
that they have you know maybe Key and
Peele it used to be Comedy Central if
you got a special on Comedy Central that
was cool it's not anymore like nobody
will say that being like Oh sick I got a
a half hour on I don't even think they
do half hours they'll do maybe like
these 10 minutes but comedy Central's
YouTube channel I've said this many
times but cuz I you know do live
streaming for uh my call-in show that I
do on Tuesday nights it's called Low
value mail if you want to check it out M
but they have 11.6 million subscribers
on their YouTube channel Comedy Central
and they'll do these live streams of
standup it's like two 300 people
watching like they've absolutely killed
their brand like killed it it's
destroyed I don't even think it could be
resurrected at this point so that's
[__] crazy yeah it's crazy I mean
think about it like you know
daily wire has to make comedy stuff
right now and I saw a thing with Jeremy
where he's saying like you know Joe
Rogan essentially was like you guys have
to make this and then he's like yeah you
know what we do kind of have to make
this because nobody else will and
there's just nobody everybody's just
wants to play it safe with especially
with comedy there hasn't been I mean
I've been beating this because this
horse because it's uh just so crazy to
me there has not been a
popular comedy movie like a big um box
office hit in now 10 years what was the
last one Ted 2 like if you look at the
top 50 comedy movies of all time by by
box office the only one like the most
recent one of those was Ted 2 wow 10
years ago like there's just you know
there and it obviously overlaps
perfectly with what's going on
culturally tell you what speaking of Ted
2 Family Guy is still going I didn't
realize that it's still going where do
you watch it I I've seen clips of it or
whatever fox on Fox yeah Simpsons to um
but that seems to have really I don't
know I remember in 10 15 years ago
family guy was like [__] crazy hot
yeah this is going to be this it made
South Park almost look slow in some way
like more cool and more cutting and the
the characters were kind of a bit more
lovable and now it I don't know yeah I
haven't I I you know what I can't even
comment on it I have not seen Family Guy
in a long time I'm sure it has its it
moment but again it's just one of those
things where it's probably just it's a
big money maker they're not going to
really be able to replace it with
something that is comparable yeah Jimmy
Carr taught me about this idea of uh
trajectory being more important than
position so if you are 100th in the
world at a thing but last year you were
200th in the world there is more Allure
and excitement around you than if you're
number three in the world but last year
you were number two so basically your
sort of trajectory is more important
than your absolute position
and you're right with what you say about
well it's cuz it's more up it's uh yeah
like there's more upside and there's
more potential and there's more unknowns
corre around it right like once you're
two you go well you can only be one and
that's it and then we're done thinking
about where this could go there's no
daydreaming about what could happen here
yes yeah yeah yeah how how high could
they rise maybe even higher than the
highest person but yeah that sort of
slow decline but yeah man I it's one of
those things I can totally see it why
people would sacrif ifce credibility or
cool or whatever and it's not like they
always purposefully do this sometimes
people just like make calls that tweet
things or say things or do whatever
that's like H [__] I thought that was
kind of cool or interesting or whatever
right at the time and it didn't be it's
not everything is a rational purposeful
decision but a good chunk of it is just
not keeping your eye on the ball and
you're right Comedy Central to go from
where they were to where they are now
and it was just all the kind of you know
not to sound like some crazy like Boomer
or whatever but like it really was the
diversity stuff because they were uh you
know when I I think everything got like
it was almost like a hockey stick when
Trump showed up like in terms of this
massive over overreaction course
correction kind of thing but you know
they wrongly were overemphasizing like
white guys like when people say you know
they were they they put too many of them
and but the problem is is is how do you
you know like you can't just like
exactly um represent everybody like it's
that's like communism essentially like
what we're going to have a exact
representation of every person 12.5% you
know what I mean it's like it's
literally impossible so they were overid
it one way and now they and then they
went and they overdid it the other way
but with comedy the problem was is that
sometimes like you can't just I know
that you want to keep your jobs right
and the only way to do so at the time
was to say hey we need to like really
make this super diverse but like there
just wasn't the people available to do
that like you can't like you can't just
say hey this person's checks these three
boxes you're like but that person's been
doing stand up for three months they're
just not good it's not nothing against
them and like I don't blame those people
for taking that uh thing but you're like
that's just not how art should be it's a
ruthless position almost to put the the
elected person into as well because
what's going to happen that they're
going to say no they're going like
they're not going to say no but if they
say yes then they they kind of by all of
the people in the industry that actually
care they feel like they've got an
unfair leg up and then they're right
okay so I say no to this and I maybe
never get this opportunity again you
never say no you never like comedians
are never rarely turning down any
opportunities like that so yeah you just
you take the opportunity and and then
but if you go look at the comments right
like like comedy go look at Comedy
Central standups Instagram page right
they've kind of I think they've kind of
seen the error of their ways but in
class Bally way too late but it's all
these people who followed them for Bill
Burr and Dave Chappelle and then they
just started putting all these just kind
of essentially amateur comedians on for
the purpose of diversity which is truly
self-serving because it was for the
purpose of these people keeping their
jobs right because they essentially it
was like the tide came out and they were
like man you know the Tide's out and
we're we [__] up we we put too many
white people on or whatever so then now
we have to overreact and then all the
comments are like what is this [__] like
people are like this where's the you
know you got like where's the joke and I
feel bad for uh the diverse people who
are actually good because then when they
get put up people will think it's for
the purpose of diversity right and
you're like so it's unwinable
position because if they wanted to say
hey we're going to put the best people
on then there was a chance that it might
not be representative enough quote
unquote cuz the thing is there was you
know when I started comedy which is 15
years ago a lot of women would fairly or
or at least say like you know they would
be the tokenized person on a show right
they would say like we already have one
woman on the show kind of like you'd
hear that like a show with eight people
but also they were about that ratio of
comedians like it wasn't ever 50/50 like
ComEd is a guy thing or at least was and
then you know when this stuff started
happening they were like okay we need
50/50 and you're like that is not how
comedy shes out the barel of wom that's
not how comedy shakes out like it's not
50/50 like it's not if you took a master
list of all comedian it's not half women
it's probably now a quarter well I tell
you one interesting thing that I
realized was uh I come from a nlife
background the number of female DJs
right because you can be a good DJ you
can be an allright producer and a very
very good DJ so people go to see people
that play good club sets that don't
necessarily produce and make music
that's absolutely banged and gone into
the charts
but when you're doing DJing there is
other than the selection of the things
it's not like you don't know who's doing
it if I listen to a podcast with a guy
or a podcast with a woman like I know I
hear what's coming out to them and also
they have different talking points too
but with DJing it's like if I press a
[__] Testa track or if a chick
presses a Testa track it is the exact
same thing happens right so from a
performance standpoint it's completely
egalitarian but from a lifestyle
standpoint do you want to just pack and
hack and live in hotels and be on the
road and be up until 4 in the morning
for 150 days of the year like is that a
lifestyle that you actually want but if
you want to try and get 50/50
representation you're going to have to
like dig into population rather than uh
like industry yeah demographics yeah for
sure and you have to find people who are
you know maybe I don't know if in the
world of DJing not as qualified or
whatever but I mean again this is
communism like like when all this stuff
when we were in Canada and we were
making stuff and then and the tide
started to turn on this stuff and like
Ryan would have like a show at CBC and
CBC would say like uh they literally
send him a spreadsheet where you say you
have to have all these things and it was
funny because Ryan was the writer
director producer so that's all white
guys and so Ryan's essentially like I
have to like fire
myself right cuz which is weird cuz he's
like one I don't need a uh I like I
don't need a director I want a director
myself I want to I want to do all this
stuff myself but then cbc's like well
you're literally three white guys in
this scenario but then I would show my
mom he's one third of a white guy
technically teally well no you know
that's the problem is he's not two jobs
away from people of color literally
that's how they see it and then and I
told my mom this and my mom was like
yeah that's that's like what Russia was
like like that's like what living in
communist Russia was like like you and I
get I get it look there's always going
to be someone getting the short end of
the stick it's there's no and that's why
I you know don't get too you know when
I'm on get told like hey we we we're not
seeing you know when I was doing acting
in Canada they'd be like hey if you
weren't a white guy maybe we could help
you out but just that's how it's going
and I never really got too work up over
it because there's always been someone
who was told that yes it's always
someone's always going to get the the
short end of the STI you just got to
take it you know like I don't I I don't
really know I'm not going to be like
making my identity and complaining about
it I just go okay fine I'll I'll figure
out a way and I have you know so uh and
thankfully there's YouTube and the
internet and all that stuff where
everybody can kind of carve out their
own thing hell yeah dny let's bring this
one home where should people go they
want to keep up today you can find me on
Twitter Danny jokes unfortunately on
Instagram Danny jokes 2.0 I'm hopefully
will get my old Instagram regular Danny
jokes back but if you want to find me on
Instagram uh Danny jokes 2.0 Boys cast
as you see right here uh my my my life
partner yeah my pleasure my uh Ryan long
who is on the road right now but we do
new episodes every Friday on YouTube uh
youtube.com/ thee boyscast and I do a
Callin show that I had I referenced that
had Yan gillo on I had Mark Dice on
recently and it's I just love kind of
like talk radio I've always been like a
talk radio fan I don't know why but uh
every Tuesday night at 900 PM called Low
value mail m a i l and that's the name
of the YouTube channel and uh you can
check it out it's a fun time it's the
only podcast where you can watch and
call in and be on as you're watching
even though even though it's just a
radio show but it's on YouTube but yeah
man appreciate it buddy appreciate you
too than you if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe